I know of the fish I hear those are get
Turkish pepper oh okay this legit looks
like a rock ever tested as charcoal one
to Flickr no bad yellow how that so do
Swedish people think this is spicy now I
want to make it hot now I think if we
bite into it I guess my team yeah
Monty Turk I mean black licorice is
already the worst candy ever yeah why
would you solve it so he's exploded in
my mouth there's not spicy just awful
happy choose that's a really cute name
good night a lot of these are resembling
stones these are weird candies yeah yo
marshmallow okay Oh baby
sour sour and sour shower this looks
like it's gonna be caramel but then it's
not they really know how to play this
flavor rollercoaster yeah it's like free
how does a good chewiness
I like these all Greensville are oh
these sweeties finish these marshmallows
it look kind of like gum that someone
chewed up and then spit out oh man no
it's like all I'm gonna be thinking oh
they're little rabbits I think they're
like little automobiles no their cars
else today I'm 53 yeah 1953 Mason
oh this is horrible I couldn't package
something fragile with these hmm
different it's really hard to chew I
would eat a whole bag of these like at
the movies
big ones better okay I might spend my
money of it I like her rip to nighter
sudha and so town there's like Grandma
so what's with all the black candy these
are like glistening I don't like that
yeah I don't know if these are sweating
there's like medicine this is pleasant
it's like vaguely strawberry and it's
not really like warhead level there's
something inside oh it's salt oh god I
just got the salt why is it dragged I
just tasted sugar and then shower mine
like release like a puff of salt I will
say though that this lasts a really long
time
happy chilled Club Cola I don't know I'm
just having a hard time trusting the
Swedish people right now but I'm excited
for this lab nope
is it marshmallow what cousin guys
that's fun I love this do you love this
or actually do this is amazing oh my god
why is this not a Girl Scout cookie
it tastes like ice cream yeah without
the coldness they weren't that weird
they were just different all of these
have been constantly surprising none of
these have been what I expect you know
after eating this I would be like oh
yeah I would visit Sweden hey happy tits
like Cola yeah happy to look let's take
yesterday I have eaten psycho everybody
so fish peeper Turkey is it like than
just their Justin Bieber have you been
listening to Turkish Peter he's so good
he know I love him he's like Oh